in the weather here you have Bock on ne short after
Italy and the best climate friendly and comfortable
with the AB Nuremberg.
here it is no problem at all,
because you come from here with only one change
fast and convenient for example to ROM,
to Milan or even to beautiful Venice.
which is stupid, however,
when you're not on the road with Interior,
often need several tickets
and of course that's super time-consuming to research,
super exhausting to book
and actually only suitable for such nerds like me.
so that rail travel in Europe in the future
becomes much simpler,
we want green 1 european
Create ticketing system,
so that you reach over
according to the principle of a trip 1 ticket
can easily book train tickets and
so that Europe is even better on the rails
can grow together.
so go on 09.06 to the
Europe Choose and choose 1 easier train ride in whole
Europe.